hey gordon long time no see
yeah it's been a hell of a couple years
i can't believe i'm i'm saying this but
you know it's really
really nice to see you thank you i have
a feeling that you'll find some way no i
have no
no i have no intention of hurting you
i'm serious i know how
i know how important celebrities are
especially in times of global crises
ryan reynolds is back with another
hilarious ad this time the
vancouver-born actor reunites with his
faux twin brother gordon
while promoting the merger of his
marketing company maximum effort
with mountain kicking off the
conversation ryan and his
twin addressed the pandemic and the
celebrity favorite dating app
raya what are your thoughts on the
pandemic seemingly coming to a close
well like a lot of people i'm excited to
get back on raya
was blake upset when she discovered
uriah profile or when you accidentally
clicked on her
raya profile gordon then pokes fun at
ryan's movie roles
making note that he always seems to be
switching bodies
some call you um the king of the body
switching movie
nobody calls me that to your face bolt
neck
the changeup selfless detective pikachu
criminal the voices and to a lesser
extent this ad masquerading as a tired
fake twin brother sketch are you uh are
you hard up for money or are you just
trying to scratch some sort of creative
std
i'm not hard up for money but you sold
the gin company yes
to diageo and as things get heated
between the two
the deadpool star eventually storms off
okay
i'm ending this i'll see it thanksgiving
no stop stop it
sally sells seashells
happy hot butter hopscotch i'm outta
here
bye